[Music]
this is no Hollywood production it is
what residents of this ancient city have
long feared would happen nine stories
high sixty five thousand tons capable of
carrying 2500 passengers and out of
control
[Music]
the MSC opera plows into Venice's key
side
some in the ships path seem oblivious to
the potential danger they're in others
are filming from up on the deck and
wondering why people on the dockside are
not running
[Music]
the announcement Delta echo is code for
the crude damage to the ship and
collision imminent
although it's going to feel
the tugboats which are used to guide
cruise ships in were despite trying
unable to stop it
and so it cut a wedge between the
dockside and a smaller more driven ouzo
which thankfully remained upright was
clearly a frightening moment for
everyone involved
I saw the tip of the ship that was
rapidly approaching and it seemed like
it was coming towards my flat and in
fact it ended up squeezed there I heard
this deafening noise coming closer the
sound of the horn
we were lucky because it could have been
much worse in a statement the ship's
operator gave no detail on what had
happened saying only that a technical
issue caused the vessel to graze the
dock and collide with another boat it
didn't take long for an already
established protest movement to gather
from the pollution they caused the sheer
weight of tourists they bring to the
island city and now the danger they pose
physically to these cruise liners are
deeply unpopular ministers haven't done
anything at all the ships continue to
pass through the heart of the historic
city from one part of the city to the
other they're putting us in danger not
only with all their smoke and the
pollution but also our safety as this
morning clearly showed
[Music]
it is remarkable that there were not
more injuries regardless though many
here will hope this becomes a turning
point the catalyst to change laws and
introduce a more sensible approach that
protects tourism at the city to mark
stone Sky News in Italy